chinese mortgage holders have been
withholding repayments on mass as they
wait for their homes to be finished as
patrick fock reports many borrowers have
been left in dire straits
as you approach this part of hernan
province by train you see it bears all
the hallmarks of china's growing crisis
in the distance unfinished construction
projects scattered across the city
this is jumadyan a city of around 7
million people in southern hernan
province
lichen bought a home here in 2018 for
just over half a million yuan the
equivalent of around 75 000 euros
the developer was meant to complete the
project in 2020 but ran out of funds
lee didn't want to show his face on
camera fearing possible retribution but
he was fed up and desperate to speak out
about what's happened to him
i bought the apartment in 2018.
it was agreed it would be ready in 2020
but they stopped work in 2019 and
they're still not working on it now
the apartment
the day we visit other home buyers come
to meet lee as well
among them an elderly woman with three
young girls in tow she's their
grandmother
their parents are migrant workers and
live far away in the south saving for
the family she looks after them here
she says she fears their home will never
be finished and the girls won't have
anywhere to live
well one of the things that's really
extraordinary here and really gives you
a sense of the scale of the problem is
this whole road is lined with unfinished
buildings one after the other as far as
the eye can see
the homeowners here say there are
thousands of people in jumadian who have
bought unfinished homes
with nowhere else to go some are even
considering moving into these ramshackle
buildings
but there are hundreds of thousands of
others across china in similar
situations who are simply refusing to
keep up mortgage payments that may be a
problem on not just on the
developers but also for the for the
banks and also for the economy as well
patrick wong is a real estate analyst
with bloomberg intelligence
he says policymakers may need to shake
up the practice of buyers paying
developers before completion
nearly 90 percent of all homes in china
are pre-sold as in the past we really
rely on the pre-sale conscious content
sales to fund
project development or to fund
even the internal financial resources or
buying new land the crisis has piled
pressure on the government and stirred
social unrest
many people have expressed sympathy for
victims like lee
i just want everyone to be able to see
that ordinary people are drowning in
misery
[Music]
if left unresolved for many the
consequences could be crippling
for more on this i'm joined in the
studio by our resident china watcher
clifford kuhn and clifford we heard the
phrase they're drowning in misery it's a
miserable time for the people that own
these apartments have they got any hope
of them ever being finished
looking at the situation and the crisis
that faces the uh property sector in
china at the moment it's hard to see how
they're going to find the money to pay
for these apartments to be finished uh
the value of the property market has
lost a trillion dollars in the last year
which is astonishing
and the property market accounts for a
third of the whole economy so you can
see that this is a major major problem
that they're dealing with so i think um
it's going to be very difficult for them
to find find a way around um the current
crisis that they're finding they're
facing
the government in beijing has been
putting a lot of pressure on developers
and on banks as well but how much
pressure is the communist party under
itself given what's happening and how
people's lives are not improving in the
way that they usually expect in china
well if you look at these these problems
are all connected in a way you have the
20th party congress coming up in october
16th which was announced yesterday the
date uh at which uh leader xi jinping
will will get an unprecedented third
term and in the me in the run-up to that
date nothing is going to be allowed to
happen uh which means that efforts like
by foreign bondholders to get their
money back
i don't really think they're going to
have much of a chance really unless they
decide to just pay them off to to keep
things calm but everything has to be
calm and the run up to this um at the
same time a lot of the lending that
caused the crisis comes from local
government um and and state banks so
it's all kind of connected it's um it's
part of one larger problem and in order
to resolve it it's going to have to be
addressed on many different fronts and
until this party congress takes place
and until the party shows more
willingness than it has up till now to
address the problem i just don't see a
resolution coming
you mentioned bondholders actually
bondholders in evergrand have taken
things into their own hands and proposed
their own debt restructuring plan
what's the situation with everground now
yeah well i think evergrant is just
looking at on the share side um the
analysts are saying the shares are worth
nothing um everyone is expecting it to
go bankrupt um it's got this
restructuring is sort of a last-ditch
attempt i think to try and get some
money out of it but foreign investors
because of this complicated structure
that we have foreign investors are going
to be way down the food chain when it
comes to getting any money out of this
situation so they're going to really
struggle i think to get their money it's
it's um again as i say a last-ditch
effort um but i think the priority is
going to be given to the domestic
lenders um unless they want to really
show that um they are trying to address
the issue and they do come to some kind
of compromise with the foreign investors
so beyond the the congress when it comes
up later this year is that is there any
hope of a resolution to the the property
and debt crisis
well it's just so large that it's very
hard to see where where a solution is
going to come from because um you know
you've also got a slowing economy
because of the zero covert policy which
means there's less
legroom um
or leeway to to uh you know improve
things and um so there's no real end in
sight given the the economic
fundamentals that they're facing right
now
you